[موسيقى]
من المظهر الكلاسيكي لبن هوجان
وأرنولد بالمر إلى
التصاميم الجذابة التي يرتديها
أسلوب باين ستيوارت للجولف وملابس الجولف
كانت في تطور مستمر
لم يكن هذا التطور واضحًا في أي مكان
أكثر من الأحذية
ذات التصميمات الخالية من الشوكات والجديدة  المواد التي
تؤدي إلى
مستوى غير مسبوق من الاختيار
والابتكار في العرض ،
أعتقد أن ما أصبح واضحًا
حقًا خلال السنوات الثلاث إلى الخمس الماضية
هو الراحة هو King
Mason Dennison هو المدير العالمي لأحذية الجولف
لشركة Adidas الألمانية العملاقة للملابس الرياضية
الذي قاد الطريق مع ابتكارات جديدة
تأثرت التصميمات بأمثال
داستن جونسون
جون رام ودانييل كانغ ، سيصدر هاتفي
رنينًا أحيانًا وتخبرني مستعمرة الغبار
أنه
يشعر بملمتين أقل في الحذاء الذي
يختبره
ويريد معرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاننا تعديله حتى يتمكن هؤلاء
الرياضيون  دانييل كينج
جيس كوردا زاندر دي جي سيرجيو
واكو كل الرياضيين الذين لدينا عبر
جولة lpga pga للرجال لدينا هي amaz  حول مدى مشاركتهم
في الاحتفال بالأسياد لهذا العام ، أصدرت أديداس
حذاء غولف ستان سميث على غرار
تصميم السبعينيات الأيقوني والذي أصبح كلاسيكيًا رياضيًا وأزياءً ،
أعتقد أننا تحدثنا عن تغيير اللعبة
خاصةً في السنوات الثلاث إلى
الخمس الماضية.
عندما تنظر إلى هذا العام
، كان حقًا احتفالًا
بعودة ستان بمزيد من الاستدامة
وقد كنا متحمسين حقًا عندما سمعنا
عن ذلك
لأننا ندفع الاستدامة في
لعبة الجولف لعدة سنوات
الآن وهو الشيء الوحيد الذي نتمتع به حقًا  أردت
التأكد من أننا إذا أحضرنا
ستان سميث إلى لعبة الجولف ،
فقد فعلنا ذلك بطريقة منطقية
للاعب الجولف ،
لذا فإن ستان سميث الذي أحضرناه إذا نظرت
إليه من
مسافة يبدو وكأنه لاعب عادي مثل ستان
سميث  سوف تشتريها وقد رأيت على
مدار الخمسين عامًا الماضية
مع استمرار شركة Adidas والعلامات التجارية الأخرى
في ابتكار
تصميمات أحذية الجولف التي تشبه بشكل متزايد
التصاميم التي قد تراها في
الرياضات المختلفة
أو  كخيار للأزياء ، أعتقد أن هذا
ما يريده المستهلك ، وأعتقد أنه
يريده
بغض النظر عن الفئة التي
يمكن أن تكون كرة القدم مرة أخرى ،
وهم يمارسون كرة السلة ، يريدون منتجًا للأداء
ولكنهم يريدون أن يتم
استخدامها في المزيد من البيئات ، فماذا
يفعل  عقد المستقبل
لتصميم الأحذية الخليجية ، أعتقد أن
هناك إثارة مع لعبة الجولف
والتي من بعض النواحي لم تطمح إلا
للكهرباء ، فهناك الكثير من الوافدين الجدد إلى
لعبتنا وهم يأتون
ويطالبون بأساليب مختلفة
ومستويات مختلفة من
الأداء ونحن '  إعادة متحمسة لأنها بالنسبة لنا
فرصة لتنمية اللعبة
للجميع وهي فرصة
لدفع اللعبة إلى الأمام
وهذا ما نحن بصدده في adidas
للجولف هو دفع الطبيعة التقدمية
بما في ذلك المزيد من الأشخاص الذين يتمتعون بالاستدامة
ويصنعون
تقنيات عالية رائعة  منتج الأداء